[Musique]
france 2022 l'heure du choix c'est comme
chaque semaine notre rendez vous avec
catherine verdier dès la semaine
prochaine un rendez-vous qui deviendra
quotidien à strasbourg soir raphaël ça y
est on a la liste officielle donc des
des candidatures à la présidentielle des
10 et 24 avril prochains douze
candidates et candidats ont donc
rassemblé 500 parrainages en provenance
de 30 départements différents alors dans
l'ordre officiel établi par tirage au
sort il s'agit de nathalie arthaud de
lutte ouvrière fabien roussel du parti
communiste du président sortant donc
emmanuel macron pour la république en
marche de jean lassalle du mouvement
résistons de marine le pen du
rassemblement national d'eric zemmour du
parti reconquête de jean-luc mélenchon
pour la france insoumise anne hidalgo du
parti socialiste de l'écologiste yannick
jadot valérie pécresse pour les
républicains on va y arriver de philippe
poutou du nouveau parti anticapitaliste
et enfin de nicolas dupont aignan pour
debout la france est à j moins 34 du
premier tour la campagne va peut-être
enfin pouvoir démarrer maintenant
donc le président sortant est entré dans
l'arène il faut dire que la guerre en
ukraine a une fois encore tout éclipsé
ou presque durant la semaine écoulée
l'horeca politique est signée florent
rodo shirli sitbon et autres richesses
c'est l'histoire d'un ralliement qui
n'était plus un secret pour personne
fragilisée par ses positions sur le
conflit ukrainien est en recul dans les
sondages eric zemmour havas la carte
marion maréchal nièce de sa rivale
marine le pen
elle est belle et de la
mairie
absolument convaincu qu'eric zemmour est
le mieux classé dans cette élection sont
financiers on entendre qu vous avez déjà
commencé à construire cette réunion à
droite tu es unique réussi à survivre
chercher une prise symbolique qui aurait
été un événement si la guerre ne faisait
pas rage en ukraine
à lyon meeting pour la paix de jean luc
mélenchon histoire de dissiper les
critiques de ses rivaux qu'il accuse de
complaisance vis-à-vis du kremlin
nous portons un message à cet instant
stop à la guerre stop à l'invasion de
l'ukraine
habana rebelles qui envahit l'ukraine
l'insoumis regrette la fourniture
d'armes à l'ukraine pas yannick jadot
manifestation de soutien à paris le
confirme fini le traditionnel
antimilitarisme des écologistes
[Applaudissements]
et continuer d'armer la résistance
iranienne nous étions tellement heureux
en france tentent les anglais et les
américains mais la résistance
[Musique]
à l'extrême droite la question des
réfugiés ukrainien divise accueille sous
conditions pour eric zemmour marine le
pen elle ouvre la porte mais seulement
le temps du conflit discours bien
différent de celui tenu lors de la crise
syrienne ça veut dire
aux femmes et enfants qui fuit oui je
sais voilà on les accueille les on est
mais on les met en sécurité le temps que
à gaza un accueil à géométrie variable
indigne de la france selon fabien
roussel on voit là toutes les limites de
leur discours comme si aujourd'hui il
était possible de trier les réfugiés de
les trier en fonction des guerres en
fonction des pays où se déroulent ces où
se déroulent ces guerres
cette guerre emmanuel macron ne veut pas
lui tourner le dos président désormais
candidat il a lancé sa campagne façon
netflix il faut que le candidat puisse
présenter son projet au pays mais il
faut aussi que le président continue à
faire son travail donc vraiment un seul
candidat et 1,80 m
à
[Musique]
un chef de l'état dont les adversaires
valérie pécresse en tête souhaitent ils
descendent enfants dans l'arène
démocratique le bilan des manuels macron
a des allures de dépôt de bilan il faut
qu'il y ait dans les semaines qui
viennent un vrai débat démocratique dans
notre pays
c'est sans d'avoir un débat démocratique
projet contre projet
allez pour finir petit pas de côté avec
ses quelques pas de danse au salon de
l'agriculture esquissé par marine le pen
copier ensuite par eric zemmour sans
oublier bien sûr le paquito d'un jean
lassalle ivre de bonheur
voilà c'est tout pour cette semaine
vivement la prochaine
emmanuel macron a donc officialisé sa
campagne jeudi dernier en mettant fin à
un faux suspense très critiquée par ses
concurrents à la présidentielle qui
l'accusent de vouloir effacer tout
simplement le débat démocratique à
chauray louis raphaël et pour les
maquereaux nist au contraire la faute
revient aux adversaires du président
incapable d'imposer leur thème dans
l'opinion en tout cas c'est leur avis la
faute aussi à l'agenda diplomatique très
chargé du chef de l'état en lien avec la
gare en ukraine il effectue tout de même
ce lundi son premier déplacement de
candidat poissy dans les yvelines marie
schuster vous êtes sur place bonsoir
marie premier déplacement donc pour
emmanuel macron qui prend la forme d'une
conversation avec les habitants de la
ville
oui emmanuel macron avait prévenu que le
contexte géopolitique ne lui permettrait
pas de mener une campagne dite
traditionnelle donc exit les marées de
drapeaux bleu blanc rouge ce soir pour
sa première sortie en tant que candidat
le président emmanuel macron a choisi de
rencontrer quelques 300 habitants de la
ville de poissy pour une sorte de
conversation à bâtons rompus une sorte
surtout de redites du grand débat une
rendre à un rendez vous beaucoup plus
intime choisi par le président candidat
puisque l'image la volonté derrière tout
ça et d'afficher une image d'un
président qui est resté proche de ses
électeurs pour la proximité il compte
néanmoins davantage sur ses militants
sur le terrain des militants que nous
avons rencontré le week-end dernier avec
claire paquet l'un sur un marché de
paris dans le 15e arrondissement
premier week-end de campagne officielle
pour le camp d' emmanuel macron armé de
sa lettre adressée aux français les
militants du parti présidentiel sont en
marche
ma lettre aux français et l'avenir
voter pour le oui alors votre
le quinquennat d'emmanuel macron a créé
sa part de déception martin à manifester
aux côtés des gilet jaune lorsque les
militants dans marche lui propose un
tract elle explose
facile de donner des petits papiers ou
jean descamps tianma leurs seins on vous
voit plus sur le marché on n'entend plus
parler de vous parce que vous avez été
élu pendant cinq ans et vous vite et
très bien à vos petits trucs alors
arrêtez madame arrêté
la passe d'armes fini par s'apaiser je
fais mon mea occupe pas regarder je vais
vous en prendre un il dit j'ai appris
sur ce marché parisien l'heure n'est de
toute façon pas au débat la guerre en
ukraine et dans toutes les têtes et
plongent les électeurs dans la peur du
lendemain on n'a pas le temps de s'y
intéresser en fait ni le temps ni
l'envié au final 4 mai au millennium
finalement on se dit voilà on va garder
notre président il a un boulevard au
fait ce qui l'avantagé avec mac os et
qu'il a il a prouvé quelques trucs quand
même par rapport à d'autres les autres
il faut que parler
emmanuel macron part favori mais la
stratégie est de ne pas s'avouer
vainqueur non ce n'est pas plié je crois
qu'il faut toujours se méfier de ce
sentiment là c'est le pire en politique
l'arrogance peut tuer l'humilité jamais
il reste moins de cinq semaines avant
l'échéance présidentielle
cinq semaines durant lesquelles emmanuel
macron devra convaincre sur la base d'un
programme qu'il n'a pour l'heure pas
rendu public on va maintenant revenir
sur le début de campagne d' emmanuel
macron une entrée en campagne donc très
simple avec une lettre publiée dans la
presse quotidienne régionale jeudi
dernier simple mais mise en scène tout
comme son clip de campagne qui a
beaucoup fait réagir et s'il est allé à
la rencontre des français donc
aujourd'hui pas de débat prévus pour
l'heure avec les autres candidats
roselyne febvre bonsoir on va en parler
avec vous situation donc pour le moment
très confortable pour le président
candidat très confortable un bain on y
rentre de plain pied en fait aujourd'hui
dans cette campagne alors où tout est
propre et où tout est maîtrisé c'est
entre l'appartement témoin ou villages
potemkine c'est à dire que il ya eu 7
cette lettre aux français inquiets ou on
voit bien que le président a choisi en
quelque sorte un ton
pas neutre mais un peu ennuyeux voilà et
ensuite le lendemain une petite vidéo
surprise où on voit le président montré
quatre à quatre les les escaliers avec
son chien et le réalisateur qui lui pose
une question terrible mais alors c'est
plié monsieur le président et le
président qui prend un air outré en
disant mais absolument pas donc voilà il
veut montrer que cette campagne a quand
même lieu avec le risque effectivement
qu'on le critique parce que la guerre
écrase tout et que quiconque va le
critiquer en quelque sorte sera accusé
est bien de ne pas jouer l'unité
nationale donc c'est un pas c'est un
chemin pavé n'ont pas de rose parce
qu'il ya la guerre pour pour emmanuel
macron mais en tout cas un chemin assez
facile qu'il emprunte facilement avec
dans le fond des adversaires trois qui
sont atteints de poutine y est aiguë et
on a bien vu que ça ne leur portait pas
bonheur un président qui est qui a pris
quatre points dans les sondages et qui a
pris neuf points dans le baromètre de
l'opinion donc tout ça est très est très
bien pour emmanuel macron bien
évidemment en tout cas aujourd'hui ça
paraît extrêmement facile
alors ce soit réglé dans une ville des
yvelines avec un maire divers droite
mais qui est copain macron et qu'il aime
beaucoup donc il a choisi ses 200 et 300
personnes dans le fond qui ne le
bouscule pas vraiment donc il reprends
sa formule qui marchait bien qui était
celle du grand débat parce que les bleus
les français ont besoin alors je suis
pas sûr que ce soit le cas ce soir parce
qu'on appelle la purge démocratique
c'est à dire de parler de dire leur
mécontentement de participer au débat
est là où il va falloir que emmanuel
macron ce soit soit quand même un peu
vigilants c'est qu'aujourd'hui personne
ne fait le bilan de son action qu'il n'y
a pas pour l'instant d'émissions de
télévision de débats avec les
adversaires et qu'on pourrait lui
reprocher s'il gagne et bien d'avoir
écrasé le débat appelé politique est en
quelque sorte de lui dire mais dans le
fond si vous êtes élu quelle légitimité
avez-vous c'est le risque qu'il prend
mais on peut imaginer que le président
va être plus intelligent que ça et
et donc faire à un moment proposer des
émissions il y aura du débat de la
contradiction merci beaucoup roselyne et
on vous retrouve dès demain pour votre
émission mardi politique avec frédéric
rivière de rfi vous recevez le candidat
écologiste yannick jadot ainsi que
nicolas bay donc vice président du parti
reconquête d'eric zemmour mais pour
qu'il va donc voté à présent notre
électorat nous allons évidemment la
rencontre du corps électoral comme
chaque semaine est aujourd'hui bien
direction la banlieue parisienne à
bagnolet h rennes wind site est coupé du
centre ville de bagnolet par l'autoroute
c'est la cité de la noue alors les
habitants décidé de faire de cet
enclavement un atout en multipliant les
initiatives locales sous l'impulsion
d'un homme alassane diallo directeur du
centre socioculturel de la noue donc
véritable tisseur de lien c'est un
reportage signé julie d'une de l'ofs
georgia ce bec et florence vinit
je suis né au sénégal je suis arrivé en
france l'âge de 2-3 ans et j'ai grandi à
la noue depuis 1984 c'est un quartier
aujourd'hui dix quartiers prioritaires
c'est ici que j'ai trouvé toutes les
briques qui m'ont permis de faire les
fondations et de me construire email
mans est donc aujourd'hui c'est un
quartier auquel je dois beaucoup et du
coup j'essaie de rendre beaucoup à ce
quartier de manière réciproque
[Musique]
le centre culturel que je dirige
aujourd'hui vous était l'usagé de ce
centre quand j'étais enfant adolescent
à moi ce qui m'anime et je pense que
c'est le fruit de mon éducation c'est de
justement participé à réduire les
inégalités et si c'est un atelier
cuisine
les cols bleus
permet de faire de très bonnes choses
qu'on voit à la boulangerie qui sont pas
accessibles à eux qu'ils leur fassent
par eux mêmes à la maison les formes
d'entr'aide font la différence les
formes de transmission inter générations
font la différence également et c'est un
quartier où il fait bon vivre malgré
d'autres problématiques je dis pas que
tout est rose ici
[Musique]
le taux de délinquance il est très
faible le taux de réussite au bac il est
assez élevé aussi par rapport à d'autres
quartiers avant tout il faut attendre
apparemment on va pas toucher
jean-vincent placé sur l'artiste
[Musique]
et
là nous avait un maire se serait al
assad c'est en voyant l'énergie
d'alassane que moi ça m'a donné aussi
d'en partager un peu plus et de
m'investir aussi socialement avec les
gamins du quartier ou au centre social
d'à côté
moi je prends plaisir à faire exister
les autres faire société c'est aussi ça
tisser des liens évidemment tiendra
comme ça monsieur copé
si j'étais président je veillerai à ce
que les savoir faire de chaque individu
sont reconnues car aujourd'hui on est
dans une société on existe trois les
diplômes et on passe à côté des
compétences de chacun
et c'est regrettable je ferai en sorte
que la société soit beaucoup plus
inclusive et que la diversité de chacun
soient prises en compte
et pour finir les ces cadeaux c'est
notre bonus de la semaine achevée oui
avec une archive qui fait écho à la
guerre menée par la russie en ukraine et
à l'extrême inquiétudes qu'elle suscite
il s'agit d'un extrait de l'allocution
du général de gaulle du 31 mai 1960 le
président expose aux français ses
craintes pour le continent européen
après l'échec de la rencontre à paris
entre les quatre grands de l'époque
états unis urs royaume uni et france
dont l'objectif était d'obtenir là aussi
une désescalade à l'époque les tensions
s'était cristallisée raphaël autour de
la sphère d'un avion espion américain u2
abattu alors qu'il survolait le
territoire soviétique pour photographier
bien des installations militaires
écoutez le général de gaulle
deux camps se dresse face à face dans
des conditions telles qu'il ne dépend
que de moscou ou de washington qu'une
grande partie de l'humanité
ne soit écrasé en quelques heures
devant cette situation
la france juge qu'il n'ya pas de litige
territorial ni de querelles doctrinales
qui compte qu'ils tiennent en
comparaison de la nécessité de conjurer
ce péril monstrueux
et c'est tout pour cette semaine raphaël
merci h rennes 2022 l'heure du choix
c'est tout pour cette semaine on se
retrouve dès la semaine prochaine et
tous les jours dorénavant avec vous
ashwin verdien d'ici là bien sûr vous
pouvez retrouver cette édition sur nos
sites internet notre site internet
france 24 points comme ainsi que les
réseaux sociaux merci encore h rennes
restez avec nous prochain journal dans
un peu plus de trois minutes
[Musique]